كان لدونالد ترامب
علاقة مشحونة بالحقيقة
تعود إلى عقود من الزمن إلى بناء
وبيع برج ترامب حيث أدار باربرا ريس
البناء الذي زرعه في
برينسيسا كنت أبحث عن شقة
في برج ترامب ولم يحدث ذلك
مطلقًا  لكنها جعلت الأوراق على
يقين من أن الشراسة لم تكن جزءًا منها ، بل
كانت مجرد إثارة ضجة
حوله
حول ترامب ، هل ضحكتوا عليه يا رفاق أو
لأنكم لم يكن هناك شيء فظيع
بشأنه ، أعني أنك تعلم أنه كان نوعًا ما  مثل
النبض الذي تعرفه كان مثل
المبالغة في تضخيم توني شوارتز ، المؤلف المشارك
لفن ترامب للصفقة ،
لقد توصلت إلى هذه العبارة
المبالغة الصادقة التي تسميها
شكلاً بريئًا من المبالغة الآن يمكنني
أن أسميها شيئًا  لقد بعت فعليًا
مقابل مليوني دولار يمكنني أن أقول عشرة
ملايين دولار ، وأصبح ذلك
مبالغًا فيه بصدق ، فالمشكلة هي أنه
لا يوجد شيء مثل
المبالغة الصادقة ، والحقيقة هي أن
المبالغة هي كذبة لا يرتكبونها.
لم يذهبوا معًا ولم يتعاونوا معًا
أثناء الافتتاح المضطرب
لكازينو أتلانتيك سيتي تاج محل في ترامب في عام 1990
عندما لم تعمل بعض الشقق عندما
ذهبت لجنة التحكم في الكازينو إلى
هناك في يوم الافتتاح للتحقق من أنه
على الرغم من أن الأمور قد  تم القيام بالعديد من
الأشياء التي لم يتم القيام بها ، فقد أغلقوا
ثلث الفتحات التي كانت
حاسمة لنجاح الكازينوهات ، وكانت
الفتحات هي المنتج الرئيسي
لإيرادات الكازينو الذي أغلق في اليوم الثالث في
يوم الافتتاح كان مهينًا
وكارثيًا من الناحية المالية  تم ذلك فقط
لأنه ليس لديه منظمة تعرفها
بعمق ولكن لم تكن
هذه هي القصة التي قالها ترامب أن شيئًا ما يمكن أن
يسوء مثل افتتاح تاج محل وقد
قال ذلك لأن لدينا الكثير من
الأعمال هنا  لم يحدث
هذا بسبب تعطل النظام ، وليس لأننا
لم نكن نعرف ما كنا نفعله ، فقد كان لدينا
الكثير من الأعمال عند الانهيار حقًا ،
كان يكذب بشأن كل شيء
وفعل ماذا عن شيء ماكينة القمار
لقد كانوا معطلين لفترة من الوقت كانت الفتحات
ساخنة للغاية ولم ير أحدًا
الناس يلعبون بهذه الصعوبة وبهذه السرعة
كان الترتيب يفجر الفتحات قليلاً ،
كان لدينا آلات أحبها كثيرًا
كانت في الواقع في الواقع دونالد
ملفوف جدًا  صريحًا ومبالغًا في أنه
أكاذيب ثابتة تقريبًا ، فأنت تعلم ما إذا كانت
هذه هي أصغر الأشياء التي
تعرفها إذا كان لديك 2000
شخص في حدث تعرف أنه سيقول
أنه كان هناك 5000 شخص في حدث
ما عندما يبدو أنه لا يوجد سبب
للكذب لا يوجد نظام معتقد إذا كان
سينجح ، سأقوله إذا توقف عن
العمل ، سأقول عكسه
ولن أشعر بأي ندم حيال قول
نقيضه لأنني لا أصدق
أي شيء في المقام الأول عندما
يكون في  مصلحته السياسية كما فعل
في يوليو الماضي بعد مؤتمره الصحفي الكارثي
مع فلاديمير بوتين الذي كان يحاول
التراجع عن هذه الملاحظة على التدخل في الانتخابات ،
جاءني شعبي ، وجاءني كوتس وبعض الآخرين
قالوا إنهم  الحبر إنها روسيا
، لدي الرئيس بوتين ، لقد قال للتو إنها
ليست روسيا ، سأقول هذا ، لا أرى
أي سبب لماذا ستكون كذلك ،
وقلت الجملة الرئيسية في ملاحظاتي ،
بدلاً من أن تكون الجملة لا
يجب أن تكون  لا أرى أي سبب
يمنعني من عدم القيام بذلك أو لماذا لن يكون الأمر
روسيًا ، فإن رؤيته من وجهة نظره
لا يميز بين
ما هو صحيح وما هو خطأ ، إنه
تمييزه الوحيد هو ما سينجح وما
لن ينجح